we are here with america's sweetheart
and someone who just is the coolest
person on the planet jennifer aniston
you know the morning show yes
what are you channeling in that because
it's the greatest thing i've ever seen
as an actress and in your body of work
it was basically about just revisiting
some of the
shadows blind spots that i put into a
particular file
and
meeting them head-on and actually
releasing them it was like a
extraordinary therapy
better than any actual therapist that
i've been going to for years on end
because do you think that alex levy is
the closest character to you or that
you've blessed it
with some of your deepest truths yeah i
think it's a little bit of both alex
levy is people someone maybe in
particular who i have witnessed in my
life people
say a combination of people who i have
watched
and and remember thinking
i don't want to ever do that i don't
want to be that then there is sort of
the tapping into the part that wants to
have that scream into your pillow and
yell which i never was able to do
because
until i did it in front of 150
crewmember because you wouldn't let
yourself i wouldn't love myself
i didn't know how to
i like to discuss things like to have a
conversation a rational conversation
because if you're ever with someone
who's a screamer nothing gets done i
just go shut down shut down shut down
what was it about this point in your
life that you were like i've was it and
i have nothing to lose it's written it
was written for me it was written for me
it was written we talked about it
there's there's a part as you get older
that you just hit a wonderful
who gives a
rat
this is just my promise
right
yes
um
i thank you for sharing that with the
world
uh because it's cathartic for us
watching it thank you i'm serious it's i
mean i just marvel i marvel i marvel and
marvel i can't wait to do a comedy let
me tell you that
well rush me to a comedy immediately i
don't after completing that second
season i mean now when i think of hair
obviously you're the most famous head of
hair
we've got
seriously sad i mean come on the rachel
hello
so when i hear that you're doing hair
care i'm like
give it to me now
i'm on the feeder tell me about lola v
it comes out of many years of having
really unruly hair and that's always
been my struggle i paired myself with
these wonderful people that used to be
part of arden and maybe five years ago
we've started working on this
and it's we're doing one product at a
time
because it has to be perfect and that
was the first one we started because i
live for a good detangler
because when you know you rip through
your hair when it's wet is half the
damage i heard a hot tip when your hair
is wet
use a wide tooth comb because your
follicle is at its most fragile yes
please do not use a brush and break
through it especially a really bristly
brush is your is death or there's
actually wet brushes that are made for
wet hair i do love that wet brush i love
a wet brush i just discovered it oh my
god i have minis for my kids they're all
there are minis yes they you can travel
with them oh god i'm gonna get you so
many wet brushes you're not gonna i'm
just not gonna know what to do with
myself
[Music]
you